[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein Polizist auf der Suche nach
gestohlenem
[Musik]
Weißmehl damals eine wertvolle Ware mE
ist während des Krieges
[Musik]
die Suche wird zum Auftakt zu einer der
größten spionageaffären der
schweizische
flugplter revolutione
proletaria es lebe die proletarische
[Musik]
Revolution
Bundesgericht
losan ich begebe mich auf die Suche nach
Akten die den zufallspfund im Estrich
dokumentieren erstmals lässt das
Bundesgericht ein Fernsehteam in seine
Archivräume ich finde bisher unbekannte
Dokumente über die
Spionageaffäre und auch die Flugblätter
sind über 100 Jahre später noch
feinsäuberlich aufbewahrt als
Beweismittel
ich stoße auf einen beschlagnammten Pass
lautend auf einen Hans
Schreck Schreck so wird meine Recherche
bald zeigen spielt eine Schlüsselrolle
und ich realisiere auch Waffen sind im
[Musik]
Spiel und
Granate Vorsicht nicht
verenchrift stimmt bis
nicht viel
mE aber wirklich
eigenartig
jaer
was
flugblter mit zur
Revolution Waffe
schweinstoff was Granaten was für
lufschrift vors sich nicht verbeulen na
aber das ist ja unglaublich gut danke
Otto Huser eitgenössischer
Untersuchungsrichter er soll den
Waffenfund
aufklären Heuser ist ein Mann mit einer
Mission für ihn sind die Waffen und erst
recht die aufrührerischen Flugblätter
eine
Kampfansage her ist Mensch geh offenbar
wo sehr streng sehr militärisch denkt
sehr ser bürgerlich denkt bis sogar
rechtsextrem also spätere Jahre h no der
rechtsextreme
bewegig wir befinden uns im Jahr 191 in
der Zeit des Ersten
Weltkriegs seit vier Jahren tobt der
blutige
[Musik]
Krieg es ist ein wahnsinnig gewalttätige
Krieg sie Million Tote und es lütet sois
wie das Zeitalter der extreme ein also
es ist der erste Krieg mit unglaublich
massegewalt auch Mass vernichtigswaffe
moderner Technologie und auch
Masse Media und
Propaganda die Kaiserreiche Deutschland
und österreichungarn Mittelmächte
genannt kämpfen gegen Frankreich England
und das Zarenreich Russland dieses
Bündnis nennt sich die
entant später schließt sich auch Italien
der ant
an
es ist sehr qualttige
mörderis über vi Jahr hin jeden Tag
durchschnittlich 6000 tote
soldatriegsparte ganz neue
waffensystemfunden Panter
oder Gasgranate gasat s die
wel Kampf
ist wo quasi auf industriell reführt
worden ist
undprechend zum
unglaublichführt unglaublich Massaker wo
für L V damals ein absoluter
[Musik]
Schock Spionage wird in diesem abnung
ebenfalls zur neuen
[Musik]
Waffe es ist das erste Mal dass so viele
Nachrichtendienste investiert wird es
wird schnell klar dass Informationen in
diesem Krieg von entscheidender
Bedeutung sind deshalb nimmt Spionage in
diesem Konflikt eine so wichtige Rolle
ein
schwitz ist ganz wichtige Spionage
Standort geh oder man sage Dreis schiebe
Plattform erstens will es neutral ges
ich das ist für die befeindete Macht
sehr wichtige Punkt se will es h bedutet
dass man Spionage nicht im Feindesland
Betrieben muss mit sehr hohe Risiko
sondern dass man auf neutralen bodde der
feinduspioniere die Schweiz wird z zum
[Musik]
spionageparadies im Bundesarchiv in Bern
finde ich denn auch unzählige
spionageakten während das kriegsführende
Ausland überführte Spione sofort
exekutiert erhalten Sie in der Schweiz
milde Strafen und werden
ausgeschafft so finde ich hier das
Verzeichnis der wegen militärspionage in
der ausgewiesenen
Ausländer hunderte von Spionen schickt
die Schweiz zurück in ihre
Herkunftsländer Spionage ist es Riese
Business geht britische schätzig 150000
Spion 100000 halfer halfer halfer h sind
ja verschiedene Organisationen die
katholischrisverwund die wo
informationsquelleind die
Kriegsverwundeten tausende kommen im
Rahmen einer humanitären Aktion in die
Schweiz und werden Teil des
weitverzweigten
spionagenetzwerks was h mit der Hager
landrechtsverordn du das Schwiz sich
bereit erklärt v all Kriegspartei der
Kriegsverletzte und das ist natürlich
auch gerade wichtig se für für Spionage
will vi Kontakt auf mit den
Kriegs von 1915 bis 1918 werden rund 70
000 verwundete in der Schweiz
interniert selbstverständlich dienen
auch diese Menschen den
Nachrichtendienst als
Quelle vielleicht nicht GewSt was ist
die große Strategie und was läuft als
nächst aber sie könen sagen über Taktik
wie könt Sie vor wenn Sie Stürme
gnerische festige und
schützberiffet S B sagen stimmig wo da
herrscht und für das wüsen H man sich
interessiert das sind so passelteile man
noch sicher könen Bild machen über
gnerische Lager wo man ein sch sehr
wenig Zugang zu solider Information
geh die neue spionageserie Davos
1917 ganz
formidabel erhöhen sie Dosis um Dr auch
in der SRF Serie werden Kriegsverletzte
gepflegt und dienen den Geheimdiensten
als
[Musik]
Quelle mir jetzt nicht noch nach einem
Platz bei den feinen Leuten an der Sonne
verlangen tut es
weh spüren Sie das dann sind sie Zeit wo
ist her Kohlmann ohne die
Kriegsverletzten wären die Hotels
[Musik]
leer die Aktion ist überaus interessant
für die Schweizer Hotellerie denn der
wichtige florierende Wirtschaftszweig
ist durch den Krieg völlig am Boden es
gibt keinen Tourismus mehr und die
meisten Hels stehen
leer deshalb werden internierte in
Hotels untergebracht sie werden hier
gepflegt und ernährt sie arbeiten auch
sie werden
ausgebildet und vor allem die
kriegsführenden Staaten Zahlen für die
Internierung ihrer Verwundeten das
ermöglich der Schweizer Hotellerie zu
überleben
mama mama
mama
h
Hilfe jemand
helfen in der Serie kriegsinternierte
helfen die Lawinenopfer zu
bergen so auch in der Realität im April
1917 verschüttet eine Lawine einen
Regionalzug kriegsinternierte helfen bei
der
[Musik]
Bergung die kriegsinternierten eine
wichtige
spionagequelle die mediale bedinge im er
wkrieg sind ganz anders geseh der Funk
ist gerade der aufang geseh luftüberwach
pa flugzüge aber noch nicht so viel und
da ist einfach wüs V Soldate Vorort ein
wichtige Informationsquelle
gesehen zurück nach
Zürich zurück zum Zufallsfund im Estrich
und den Beginn der großen
Spionageaffäre zu den Handgranaten mit
der deutschen Aufschrift vorsicht nicht
verbeulen
vorsicht nicht verbeulen
[Musik]
tradchrift vor sich nicht
been ich finde das Foto der Handgranaten
im
Bundesarchiv Untersuchungsrichter Huser
dokumentierte den Waffenfund akribisch
seine Untersuchungen zeigen ausgerechnet
italienische Anarchisten haben den
Estrich
gemietet ich finde auch ein Bild mit
beschlagnammten
Zeitzündern Revolvern
Giftstoffen untersuchungsrichterhäuser
entdeckt noch weitere Waffenverstecke in
Zürich wiederum bei
Anarchisten im Bundesgericht losan sind
bis heute sämtliche Ermittlungsakten
archiviert Huser scheut keinen Aufwand
lässt sogar mit den Bomben
Sprengversuche
[Musik]
durchführen sein Fazit gefährliche
Waffen in den Händen von gefährlichen
Anarchisten
Anarchisten damals die große
Bedrohung Anarchismus heißt ist ja
eigentlich ich le ich lerne Herrschaft
von Menschen über andere Menschen ab
grundsätzlich denn kann ich mich als
Anarchist bezeichnen Anarchismus heißt
ein
herrschaftslosigkeit und das ist ein
breit Spektrum von politische
bestrebige muss sich natürlich
vorstellen dass der Staat noch sehr viel
mehr
he patriarchal organisiert g
obrigkeitsgläubig und
viele lo sich irgendwie dem nie F sind
als Anarchist bezeichnet wordde sind als
bedrohig empfunden wurde
entsprechend scharf ist die Reaktion von
Untersuchungsrichter
Huser
grü K sie mich mit dem Bundes ST
verbinden bitteschön
danke her
W ganz interessant für
Sie
ich
ja wir Tasche da Jacke hab Adresse
gefunden V wir hab flter gefunden
sprengstoffmunition das ganze Programm
odero die anarch im ja genau jetzt ich
mitigung
[Musik]
v
in den Akten des Bundesgerichts sehe ich
Häuser verhaftet über 100
Anarchisten sie sitzen monatelang in
Untersuchungshaft und Schweigen
hartnäckig
Huser kommt nicht weiter er findet nicht
heraus von wem die Anarchisten die
Waffen
erhielten
die Haftbedingungen sind
harsch zwei Anarchisten begehen sogar
Selbstmord und es gibt Berichte wonach
er inhaftierte
schlägt es hagelt Proteste selbst in der
bürgerlichen Presse erscheinen kritische
Artikel
[Musik]
äußer muss ich
rechtfertigen
das Interview nachgestellt mit
[Musik]
Originalzitaten ja ich habe verschiedene
Angeschuldigte weem frechen und
ungebühliche verhalt dunkelsetze ja und
was die kritisierte verpflegig ja das
der Übelstand natürlich vololg von der
kriegsrationier
undterestoff ich den will die mit der
Bücher untereinander korrespondiert er
die unsuch sehr akribisch geführt aber
akribisch e
nurinere richtig nämlich er h Anarchist
die anarchistzene in der Schwiz
wirklich radikal austrchne radikal
besitige das seid übrigens monpricht re
der
anarchistzene im Auftrag vom
Staat der garus ma besge wir haben dem
Interesse vom Staat wen ein herterchlag
GEG der Anarchismus für in treffe ist im
leesner viele Anarchisten Leben damals
im Exil in der Schweiz sie besitzt ein
tolerantes Asylrecht zudem weigert sich
die liberale Schweiz politische
Flüchtlinge
auszuliefern diearchisten sich hier
sicher organisieren sich
neu schwi so homeland vom
internationalen Anarchismus dafangs V
der J die fedation sch gründet worden
ist anarchistische strömig innerhalb von
der international Arbeiter bewegig
verschieden die auch politische
Flüchtling hab sich in der Schwiz
aufgehalten wie z.B Revolution aus dem
zahich oder die
Internationals Aufsehen der M V der
österreichische Kaiserin Elisabeth V der
populäre s
1898 Anarchist wo einfach den ruos git
die herrschenende m weg die bringen
Unheil über Völker und wir brauchen ganz
andere
Gesellschaftsorganisation Flugblätter
analysieren er will die anarchistischen
Drucker
aufspüren das
Ergebnis für Häuser eine große
Enttäuschung hatestellt dass die
Flugblätter auf Papier druckt worden
sind wo nur aus Deutschland SP aus Mang
dieut nä das Papier mit de andere
Bindemittel nm mit mit Zellulose müsen
ersetzen drum Experte klar könen sagen
das Papier das stammt etig aus
Deutschland trotz der deutschlandspur
Huser reagiert nicht er konzentriert
sich weiter auf die Anarchisten
über Huser wssen wir ja auch dass er
lang andere fte auf der Spur ges ist
respektive dass Deutschland
als als
drzieher
verfol dann eine neue Wendung in den
Akten des Bundesgerichts sehe ich im
Juni 1918 ein halbes Jahr nach dem
waffenpfund im zircher Estrich
denonziert die französische
Spionageabwehr einen Hans Schreck dieser
sei als Deutscher Geheimagent in die
Affäre
involviert dr hansre alias dr Angst
dr
feldn der durchtriebene Spion besitzt
eine Vielzahl von
[Musik]
Decknamen trotz der Decknamen Spion Hans
Schreck wird
[Musik]
verhaftet aus den beschlagnahmten
Unterlagen geht
hervor sch ein Meister der
[Musik]
Fälschung von Stempeln wie streng
geheim und
[Musik]
Siegel damit wandelt er zahlreiche
harmlose Schriftstücke um in brisante
Dokumente alles archiviert im
Bundesgericht Hans Schreck startet
eigentlich als kleiner Gauner er WCH
alsweise in einem ärmlichen Quartier
Berlins auf die Polizei verhaftet
mehrmals wegen Betrug
als rasch wird er zum raffinierten
Betrüger als der Erste Weltkrieg
ausbricht findet ihr sofort eine Stelle
beim
Geheimdienst dort ist man begeistert von
seinen
Talenten Schrecks Leben besteht quasi
nur aus Lügen es ist extrem schwierig zu
unterscheiden was bei ihm echt und was
gefälscht ist wir wissen dass er
zahlreiche decknahen besaß
und dass er bald zum Chef der Deutschen
Spionageabwehr in der Schweiz
wird Deutschland
h dasau was hat der schwizerisch
Bundesrat den 19 terroristische abteilig
vom deutsche Generalstab nennt also man
h versucht direkt über Spionage und
Sabotage im gner schade zu
die Deutschen haben ziemlich geschickt
und vorausschauend verschiedene
längerfristige Operationen
organisiert mus die Spionage verbunden
ist auch mit Sabotage mit tchsmanöver
mit Propaganda das ganzes Feld der fü V
dem gner wo Information sammelt über
möglich werdeführt werde wenn sich meh
mit Spionage und verdeckte Operation in
der Schwiz beschäftigt den seht man dass
der Lenin zog derfang von vor allem V
dcher Sitte praktizierte Strategie g ist
der Gegner im inner
destabilisieren der russische Kommunist
Lenin lebt als Flüchtling in Zürich er
leitet den bolschwiistischen Flügel der
Kommunistischen Partei und will dass
Russland den Krieg
einstellt was sie jetzt erfahren ist
absolut vertraulich ist das verstanden
denn im Gegensatz zum zahen wollen die
bolschwiik aus dem Krieg
austreten für Deutschland für
Deutschland würde die Ostfront in
Russland
Wegfallen der Kaiser könnte sein
gesamtes Militär auf den Franzosen und
den Engländer im Westen konzentrieren
und auf der Amerikaner für Deutschland
wäre es der dringend benötigte
Befreiungsschlag dan Paus hab wir diesen
revolutionär nung gefunden er nennt sich
Lenin Wladimir ilj Lenin und lebt im
exilen Zürich v d s h mit überleg dass
das ideale zitpunkt ist um quasi
Russland als Gegner ustschalte in der
Revolution das Land das Imperium LAH
legt und damit als Kriegsgegner n
Frund das Ziel der deutschen war es
Russland zu destabilisieren indem sie
den wichtigsten Feind des Zaren
einschleusen der Lenin Zug das deutsche
Kaiserreich erlaubt den bolschwiisten
Lenin und seinen Anhängern quer durch
Deutschland zu reisen nach Russland
begleitet von deutschen Offizieren
aussteigen in Deutschland streng
verboten
[Musik]
leninzog ist gut F paradeispel für
instrumentalisier vom gagner für die eig
zweack Lenin übernimmt in Russland die
Macht der Zar wird gestürzt und
[Musik]
ermördet Lenin schließt mit Deutschland
im März 1918 einen
[Musik]
Separatfrieden für Russland ist der
Weltkrieg
beendet zT was sie an wöle revolutionär
sind nach Russland zurükehrt es ist zur
russische
Oktoberrevolution also zur
bolschwiistische Revolution das hät das
ganze Land aus der vur gekobe und
schließlich ich genau das troff was
Deutschland h wöen
näaratfriede mit Russland in
brestlitowsk
198 zurück zum deutschen Spion Hans
Schreck
vor seiner Verhaftung wohnt er im
idylischen leiigen am tunersee von hier
steuert er sein
agentennetzwerk ich realisiere Schreck
ist nicht nur in den Zürcher waffenpfund
involviert er wird auch Sabotageaktionen
an Rüstungsbetrieben in Frankreich
durchführen eine Reihe von Operationen
gegen einen Schweizer industriellen
namens Bloch organisieren der im Auftrag
der Franzosen Munition
herstellt J Bloch ein erfolgreicher
uhrenfabrikant im Krieg bleiben die
Kunden weg Bloch stellt um auf
zünderpruktion es ist ziemlich einfach
dieenproduktion umzustellen auf die
Herstellung von Zündern genau das tut
Joch er stellt in seinen Fabriken Zünder
für Granaten
her der Zünder ist der Teil der auf der
Spitze der Granate sitzt und die
Explosion
auslöst Bloch beliefert Frankreich mit
Zündern für Millionen und aber Millionen
von französischen
Frauen diese werden vor allem in der
Schlacht von verardin von der
französischen Artillerie
eingesetzt der der deutsche Spion
Schreck versucht
blochszünderexorte zu
[Musik]
stoppen er ist ein Ziel für die deutsche
Spionage sie wollen ihn ausschalten weil
er die französischen Kriegsanstrengungen
unterstützt sie Unternehmen mehrere
Anläufe und versuchen eine seiner
Fabriken in die Luft zu sprengen das
klappt nicht der Sprengsatz wird
entdeckt auch in der DAV werden Zünder
[Musik]
produziert was Hans Schreck nicht
schafft gelingt in der
Serie ganz wichtig ist d so
ab Organisation selber in Krieg
interveniert
mit
Sabotageaktionen selber eigentlich Z
kriegshandlige werde n nur Information
sammelt sondern auch Versuch direkt oder
Renis das Kriegs geschehe Belus ni kann
im andere trauen es geht eines
gespenstische Spiegelkabinett vor
Spionage gagpionage V Information und
Desinformation und das FT Hal zuu
dass dem der spionageewt auch sehr
geflich wirdthode W immer riat kurierar
bewaff Lauf
zuistole
Bombe und Gas wo man denn direkt auf der
V der Spionage
versuchz dann nochmals eine neue
Wendung in den Akten sehe ich untersich
verhaftet einen angeblichen Anarchisten
namens Erwin
Bries in Wirklichkeit aber ein
englischer Agent Bries überwacht für die
Kolonialmacht England indische
Anarchisten in
Zürich ich sehe in den Akten Agent Bries
durchschaut Schrecks raffinierten Plan
der Plan Deutschland sucht die Nähe zu
indischen Anarchisten diese kämpfen für
die Unabhängigkeit von Indien gegen den
deutschen Kriegsgegner
England Deutschland instrumentalisiert
die indischen Anarchisten ähnlich wie
mit dem
leninzug alles fliegt auf weil Spion
briis die indischen Anarchisten
überwacht der BR ist ja zu der zit man
DAV 19 bis 18 ist er als Spitzel für die
englische Polizei unterwgs gesehen
der Auftrag hat die Inder in der Schwiz
auszorche und ihre bewegigen und ih
Informationen über sie meldde nach
London der Erwin briis ist sehr Schiller
die Figur g er ist ein studierten also
er hätte schwizeris Staatsbürgerschaft
erworben und
nachher wür sagen Kulturwissenschaft
studiert inologie h sich interessiert
das riesenwissen über Orient und auf der
such nach
feststellig nicht ganz zufällig
britische Geheimdienst
glandet und so wird der Spion Bries
getaht als Anarchist Zeuge wie
Deutschland indische Anarchisten
einspannt und dann h zwei
der
chatat genannt atu und der Abdul Hafiz
derftrag vom Deutche
Generalstab
der der bombplot zu organisieren das
heißt Bomben mataterial Waffe und
entsprechend
Geld in Z italianische Anarchist
wi die indischen Anarchisten bilden die
Verbindung den sogenannten go between zu
den italienischen
anarchistenztelber dass er in Züri vom
in der Abdul Hafiz aufgefordert worden
ist mit dem
Bahnhof und der Gepack abteilig vom
Bahnhof Z h sie
es christchen abkolt wo mit dem
diplomatische kuriier von Deutschland
nach Bern spediert worden ist vor und D
mit der SPB V Bern nach Zürich und W zum
BR Bü bracht und wo den der ist gangen
ist Bri die undh dass Sprengstoff ist
und hat sofort der englische
generalalkonsul in Zürich kontaktiert
und der generalalkonsul hat gesagt
machen sie wier sie die Sach genau
beobacht meldet sie was
passiert und es ist wirklich noch ein
parteag sind die sprengmateriale der V
Hais zum Cavadini das ist ein
italianischen Anarchist ehen Z
verschoben wurde nachdem wir noch
wochenlange Verhör der Englisch Agent
der BR
malzählt nämlich dass zü geworden ist
deuts Konsulat Anarchist hat mit Bombe
und Waffe beliefert ich mich die
Information vom wmeister Steiner
erinnert über die Handgranate mit
rufschrift Vorsicht nicht
verbeulen nach dem Geständnis von Spion
Bries realisiert Häuser die Rolle des
Verhafteten Schreck ist zentral doch
Spion Schreck versteht es meisterhaft
Häuser hinzuhalten er wisse von noch
mehr Bomben und noch mehr Anarchisten
vorsicht nicht
verbeulen aber für Details müsse er
zuerst von seinen deutschen Vorgesetzten
grünes Licht
erhalten Untersuchungsrichter Häuser
wartet und
wartet differenziersvermögen ist also
sehr reduziert und ist deutsch
freundlich er z.B wenn so eine
deutscheateur wie der Hand Schreck und
Aussage gemacht ist so begeister dass
aus uns fre was mit passiert wäre er ein
extreme Parteilichkeit an
tagit immerhin realisiert Häuser es ist
eine verdeckte spionageoperation des
deutschen
Kaiserreichs doch inzwischen hat sie
schrecksagentennetzwerk bereits nach
Deutschland abgesetzt Häuser kann die
Helfershelfer nicht mehr
befragen Z von Untersuch ist folgendes
der
terroristisenst rein militärische
Organisation deuts Generalstab engagiert
geflichste milie überhaupt
donisten für Sabotage und Attentat füh
imflich
hochgefährlich ausgichn Anarchist mit
Bomben und
waffenusrü der leninzug ist ja
197 im April und die verdeckte Operation
mit italianisch anarch in Z im 18 und
ich sehe D ein quasi ein Prozess des
Lernens dass Deutschland gemerkt h
vordergründig got rechn auf alsoön inner
destabilisierig vom Feind herbiführe
durch die Exilgruppe durch sehr radikale
Exilgruppe und genauso h man hoffne in
die italianische anarchiste gesetzt will
mir davusgegangen ist dass
sie destabilisier vom italianische Staat
absetz vom König und damit auch
Ausscheid von Italien herbeiführen also
es ist im Grund gen wenn man sich das
genau sehr ähnliche
Taktik noch ist der blutige Krieg in
vollem
Gang wenn der deutsche Plan geklappt
hätte wenn die Polizei nicht zufällig
das Waffendepot entdeckt hätte der Krieg
wäre wahrscheinlich anders
verlaufen konkrete vchlg
auf Ministerpräsident Minister vchlg auf
der BAH von Milano und auf die Bank
Italien Rom die Goldreserve
sind das hätte sicher die italienischen
Kriegsanstrengungen
beeinträchtigt der Krieg gegen
Österreich-Ungarn gegen die Mittelmächte
hätte sich verlängert die letzten
italienischen Siege auf dem Schlachtfeld
wären wohl nicht passiert
und österreichungarn hätte wohl nicht so
rasch um einen Waffenstillstand am 8
November
gebeten zurück ins Archiv zurück zum
Dossier
Schreck der durchtriebene Spion Schreck
schafft es die Befragungen immer weiter
hinauszuzögern dann wird er vom
Gefängnis in eine Klinik verlegt er sei
nervenkr sagt
er in den Unterlagen sehe ich was danach
passiert Schreck flüchtet aus der
klinikzelle und telegrafiert provokativ
nach
Zürich bin gut in Deutschland gelandet
entschuldigen sie meinen Schritt dr
Schreck ja es ist richtig dass ich Frau
unbeaufsichtigter
zestattet
ja es gilt ja eigentlich das Ehrenwort
des deutschen
Offiziers hätte ich denkt dass die Frau
19 m lang
Seile es zeigt ein schme wie der Heer
auf auf deutschen Aug eigentlich blind
ges blind vertraut was von Deutschland
herkomt was Deutschland macht und
insofern ist die Schreck ST Schreck für
mich eigentlich als
Zeiche dafür dass der Huser
wirklich die
sie systematisch ignoriert ja ich habe
nur gestet will ich Interesse vom
Staat ich
Bang über Sprengstoff und die
Handgranate und so weiter das Spionage
Verbrechen V dr sch
wichtigkeitrifft wo untersuch
ermittlige stattfinde befindet sich
schwitz auch in sehr vulnerable
Situation sie ist nicht losgelöst vor
der europäische entwickl Verst wenn man
sich genau Lauf
schon regelmaßig Streiks Demonstrationen
Unruhe auf der stß auch Hunger Protest
also we der lebensmittelknppheit und
versorgsang also in der Schwiz brodelt
sozial in der zit da muss man natürlich
wenn man das so erlütert muss man gich
überlecken wenn h das ganze stattfunden
das ich ja im Sommer 18 bis im früh
Sommer 19 GH das heißt zit wo soziale
sind der Schwiz und ein landesstreik
stattfindet im November
18 der
landesstreik der Bundesrat bietet die
Armee auf gegen streikende Arbeiter
das Bürgertum lebt in Angst vor einer
Revolution so auch der bürgerliche
Untersuchungsrichter
Huser der Huser hat sichre gefühlt quasi
ti bedrohig in der
Schwiz
bestigen die Spannung ist spbar und die
prozessermittlungen gen diearen von
bürgerlichen Untersuchungsrichter
geleitet
Heuser nun sagen wir das Ganze ist in
diesem Kontext äußerst
Regel dann endlich november 1918
Frieden Deutschland und österreichungarn
haben kapituliert der Krieg ist
vorbei
[Musik]
das internationale kräftevern sich so
verändert dass Deutschland der
machtstatus verloren h dass man auch in
der schwez auf die gesz stimmig recht
antideutsch wordde was vorher wirklich
anders auf auf dieutche und so ist so
Prozess einfach in eine andere
stimmigslag den über B
Gang jetzt erst findet der Prozess über
den Waffenfund im Zürcher Estrich statt
im Juni
1919 trotz der Flucht von Spion Schreck
und seinen
Helfershelfern angeklagt sind 20
Anarchisten für den Hauptangeklagten
fordert der Staatsanwalt finhalb Jahre
Gefängnis der Prozess endet mit einer
großen Überraschung das
Bundesstrafgericht findet Häuser können
nicht beweisen welche Anarchisten
tatsächlich in die Attentatspläne
eingeweiht waren wenn die Deutschen
drahzieher vor Gericht gestanden hätten
wäre es anders
gekommen das Gericht noch festgestellt
dass
die fakte oder H disleid in keinart für
verurteiligitarchist ist Zentrum
vlag gestellt hat sich aber für die Deut
Spur interessiert dielag
ist brochen und der Bundesrichter
soldati h tatsächlich
verstanden der rechtsstaatlich grundsz
Nachdruck verschaffen und da festell
dass die Sch Justiz in rechtsförmigkeit
geschaffet wo ich beruckt bin dass man
gesagt den Prozess wenn da ke beweslag
da ist wenn das irgendwelche herb
fantasier die ZH sind wo man einfach
nicht kann
substantiieren so sind dem Prozess
nochhlich der größte Teil von deer
anarchis freigesprochen wurde für Häuser
eine große schlappe
das abstr und Lüge von denlichen
Anarchist leider zu den freisprü
geführt aber der DR sch hat mir
nochestanden übrigens dass es no Waffen
verstecken
sieenbnd
leider der her hat voricht ja eigentlich
verloren WN so krass darf sag
aber einig von der vom stadürcher
Bürgertum hte gewonnen in dem Sinn
nämlich dass er zeigt dass er qultisch
scharf und hert g Die Linke vorz er ist
der bromt kurz nach dem Prozess zum
polizeichfon der Stadt Z gewählt wurde
er
hät Problem bekommen mit dem roten zri
mit dem sozialdemokratisch
regier8 n bestätigt worden Chef V der
Polizei sage das ist
so bei die Faktore
politischeellig und professionell
Unfähigkeit bedingthen hät ihn auch
nicht ein so könen brauchen auf auf som
poste und das offizielle Deutschland im
Berner Tagblatt behauptet der deutsche
Botschafter es habe nie eine
Zusammenarbeit mit Anarchisten
gegeben dan der Archiv in Deutschland
zugänglich sind weiß man
dass die behaupt von der sie völlig
falsch ist also es geht
Korrespondenz vom damalige deutsche
gesamten in Bern ja also es dementiere
vtige verdeckte Operation auch Teil vom
Spiel sowohl im erst Weltkrieg wie auch
jetzt begleitet wird das immer auch mit
der ganz große desinformations Kampagne
und m die sind absolut verglichichbar
zwischen Erste Weltkrieg und der hütige
Situation beispielsweise der Überfall
von Russland auf die
Ukraine ein klarer Verstoß gegen das
Völkerrecht auch hier verdeckte
Operationen wie die Explosion der
nordstream
[Musik]
Pipeline es ist eine
Geheimdienstoperation ein Sabotageakt
aber von wem
es gibt mehrere Spuren die Geschichte
wird es uns vielleicht eines Tages
zeigen wer dahinter steckt aber das sind
sehr aktuelle
Operationen da geht
vermutus der große Vorteil nach sag
Ukraine größere Vorteil das ist wirklich
so unter der dunglocke von vermutige
über Strategie von der einzelnen Länder
was immer klar ist es gotum ver
unsicherig schaff also ich danke
verdeckte Operationen gehörre zum
standardrepertoir von Nachrichtendienst
und von regierige also es ist wenig
überraschend dass auch im Krieg wo jetzt
herrscht verdeckt die Operationen sowohl
im Feindesland als auch in der
benachbarte Länder
stattfinde was passierte nach dem
Prozess mit dem englischen Spion Erwin
Bries frage ich mich er der damals die
verdeckte deutsche Operation
enthüllte
der muss man eigentlich als tragische
Figur bezeichnen er ist eine von den
Figur wo der spionageeweltt vom erst
Weltkrieg nicht untypisch ist ich auch
oft mit der
Polizei konfliktgade mit Nachtruhe
störig
schlägereie Handel mit pornographischen
Material mit
M
urkundfschiglagt und so weer hät
wirklich für
braucht und das Schicksal des
geflüchteten Spions Hans Schreck
zT seine Karriere im Nachrichtendienst
fort er organisiert weitere
Täuschungsmanöver beispielsweise im
Zusammenhang mit dem Völkerbund in
Genf er mcht sich auch ein in die
Innenpolitik
Großbritanniens der
handreck AG Naturell g der gern irgendwo
brilert die de wichtigeis von der
Gesellschaft
überall
Information wiren seine Spur nochmals im
Jahr
1932 diesmal in den Archiven des
französischen
Geheimdienstes es gibt dort einen
Bericht der sagt dass Schreck in SA
Louis also in der Nähe von Basel ich
zitiere liquidiert wurde
wahrscheinlich von französischen Agenten
die ihn seit einiger Zeit im Visier
[Musik]
hatten liquidiert durch den
französischen Geheimdienst auch die
Karriere des Spions und meisterfelschers
Hans Schreck endet im Alter von 52
Jahren
[Musik]
tragisch